mmm I'm really excited about this mmm
mmm do it again hey guys i'm abby Sharpe
welcome to Abby's kitchen a few weeks
ago I shared the start of a beautiful
cookbook I've been making for my parents
and my sister as little thank-you gift
for helping me plan my wedding and of
course just getting me through life in
general my family knows how much I adore
food so I thought a cookbook would
definitely be a fitting gift and let's
be honest maybe this was just kind of my
own little subtle way of giving them
some recipes and inspiration so that
maybe one day they'd have me over to
cook for me for once please know okay
well I tried anyways that's why I
partner with my friends at HP put a
healthy twist on another one of my
family's favorite recipes and to show
you how I'm turning it into a printed
tangible cookbook so this is my first
DIY cookbook but I do a lot of printing
at home so I am loving the new HP
instant ink subscription service that
detects when I'm running low on ink and
then automatically just sends it to my
door it doesn't matter if I'm printing
my recipes in color or black and white
I'm still saving up to 50% on my monthly
ink plus the quality is amazing this is
really helping keep my DIY project super
budget-friendly so this recipe was
inspired by my mom's favorite banana
bread we loved banana bread growing up
because it's kind of like a legit excuse
to eat what is essentially cake at
breakfast time and not feel guilty about
it but there are some important rules
when it comes to making banana bread in
my home rule number one no walnuts I
love walnuts nothing against walnuts I
love to snack on them but not my banana
bread number two you want to make sure
that those bananas are crazy ripe like
the more freckles the better all the
freckles and then number three even if
it is healthy it can't taste healthy I'm
sure my mom never worried about that
last one she probably just threw in as
much butter and sugar as her recipe
called for it but this is not my mom's
recipe okay this is the Abby's kitchen
version I'm a dietitian we're gonna do
it my way and we're gonna make it a
little bit healthier and boost that
nutrition value so let's do this
so this recipe is totally gluten free
for my sister
because she's got some GI issues and I
know she's trying a gluten free diet to
try to make herself feel a little bit
better so we're starting with some
gluten free rolled oats that I've just
processed in my food processor until
they reach a flower light consistency so
you don't need to use any kind of flour
in this no no kind of white refined
flour going in I've also got some
coconut flour which I love because it's
higher in fiber higher in protein and
those healthy fats of course as well
some flaxseed also really really
nutritious some baking soda baking
powder as well
some cinnamon and some salt of course we
want to add a little bit extra flavor
gonna whisk that up I'm just going to
set this aside now it's time for the wet
ingredients so we're starting with about
two cups of our super ripe bananas that
I've mashed up and like I said you want
to make sure they are getting brown
they're getting super freckly because
this way you actually don't need to add
that much added sugar because they're
already so sweet on their own a little
bit of honey action and feel free to
substitute this with maple syrup or
agave or whatever kind of sweetener you
prefer got some coconut sugar I like
using the combination here because the
coconut sugar adds a little bit of that
kind of caramely flavor some vanilla of
course you've got some almond milk here
good to go in with some eggs and then
I've got some natural almond butter this
really holds everything together it
makes it super moist
and our flour mixture goes in gonna put
a little bit of the chocolate chips
leave a little bit for the top all right
we got our baking pan put a little piece
of parchment paper I like to just press
it in so it's easy to lift it out and
for just extra reassurance a quick
little spritz with some cooking spray
and we're going little spread
nails a fun farm take another banana
half of its for snacking half its for
decorating so just kind of cut it in
half take it out of its peel gets
challenging when I sew right you got any
delicate with it going to nestle this
down the center and we're going to
decorate with a few more of those
chocolate chips right on top so this is
going to go into a 350 degree oven for
about an hour
trust me it's worth it this is why we
have these little handles so easy look
how moist that looks oh my gosh so this
piece is all for me but there's still a
whole lot of love going on for my family
and if they want seconds they can make
it themselves when they get their
cookbook so let's have a little taste -
shall we mmm this is so good I still
have a few more recipes that I need to
create for my little cookbook for my
family and I'm going to be sharing
another one of my family's favorites in
an upcoming video so of course be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out leave
me a comment below with some of your
family's favorite recipes and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen
you